kara bangies Ozlem idea in Nairobi Kenya
there are so many people living around
and there's so much violence being
around here in this area most of the
guards or the women have here in these
communities they feel being robbed of
being attached women fear to even walk
freely and express their feelings
self-defense is very important because
without that self-defense I don't think
we are including this one in boxing
there is something that we call the
stance stance is how you stand 21 two
books if you have a bad stunt you can be
beaten by your opponent when I decided
to become a professional boxer the
reaction from my friends even from some
of my family was not that positive
because they thought that I'm going
crazy somehow this sport has always been
seen to be a mere sport I was once told
that I will never have any future
without any keys and husband nothing
nothing at all
I have won three bills and now I'm a mom
and I have a daughter with nine months
old I was in the gym Thursday and
Saturday I get back being a mother is
the most beautiful gift that God has
ever given to us as a family
[Music]
James has always been there for me and
he is a very good man I don't think I
could never have a better man than he do
when having a fight coming at him it's
always helping me in preparation because
he understand the kind of work I do
[Music]
[Applause]
it doesn't matter how it proceeds what
matters is what we want our aim as a
family for you to be a very good boxer
you need to be focused discipline you
need to have that confidence you need to
be so much concentrate on what you want
when I first walk into the gym I saw
this two women doing their sparring and
hitting this heavy box and there was so
much strong I just wanted to be like
them what's the so special to stop the
violence and the replicas that is
happening in my universe from UT of
Nairobi we are trying to create an
opportunity for girls to value
themselves and be who they want to be no
matter where they come from
sara is a mother she's a fighter she's a
teacher she's a leader she's able to be
a champion the will must be stronger and
bigger than the skill that is what we
are trying to create for the girls just
to have the opportunities for themselves
and opportunity for other girls we
normally teach them awareness on safety
on how we blend life skills and boxing
talking about time management confidence
being forecast boxing teaches different
kind of skills I want to fight again as
a professional boxer because it doesn't
matter whether I gave back to baby I
still need to keep my dreams ahead so I
will continue to focus on my dreams
I'm going to find I'm going to face and
I'm looking for to fit in bigger face
[Music]